you were in wrestling for a bunch of
years before you got uh the stone cold
thing even you were part of the fabulous
blondes right that was yeah hollywood
blondes at flying brown beaumont yeah
right and and ted turner put that
together yeah
and then you left his organization and
you went over to vince mcmahon's
organization
and now you've had incredible success
right you're like the number one drawn
wrestling yeah basically down there
in wcw i was held back because the
people that were in the ring had they
had the book and they were you know had
the power so anytime you see an upcoming
threat you're going to keep that person
down i was kept down and then finally uh
i jumped off the ropes in japan right
japanese guy moved i tore my tricep off
my arm and they said well hey
based on the amount of money we're uh
paying you about the amount of days
you've been incapacitated we're gonna go
and exercise our right to terminate the
agreement i said well
this is on the phone right i said well
basically you're telling me i'm fired
and he goes
well yeah i guess so yeah you got to
send me something to write in the what
so so when you were working for ted
turner you tore your tricep right
and that's it then they they just
chucked you out like you were people
right during the
rehabilitation process you know you
should really be wrestling ted turner is
what you should be doing
it wasn't ted turner it was it was a guy
that was running that organization but
right and like you said you know i came
to the world wrestling federation and
you know they got to say for this place
they give you they give you an
opportunity and
that's all you can ask for right so you
know it's business if you if you're
buried damn football they'll you know
they'll let you run with it
right but how do you get into wrestling
i mean you know like there's no like
man i saw college probably getting a phd
out of college yeah but i saw a report
on tv you know how many guys trying to
make i mean for uh for steve austin to
be the number one guy
it's pretty amazing because i was
watching this report on tv about guys
trying to get into wrestling
i mean it is it's almost impossible
because they go to like a training camp
or something
you could go there but it's like if you
don't usually take anybody if you don't
attract the crowd if you don't turn them
on
they just turn you out yeah i mean
that's the end of it right well they
taking guys up there to make them do a
million push-ups squats and jumping
jacks
and silly stuff like that so they try to
weed out everybody that you know that's
not halfway in shape and
right i don't haven't seen a lot of the
wrestling camps i mean wwf has one
that's you know pretty good because
they're going to look at the talent
and always looking for the new guy to
come in and how did you get into it well
you know i watched it when i was a kid i
grew up in south texas so i used to
watch houston wrestling and then uh
everybody used to come in and said hey
turn the tv to turn something else on
the tv i said well [ __ ] just
let me watch wrestling and watch
whatever you want to watch right you
were fascinated i got it kept on through
that and then after college uh my
scholarship ran out and i used to go the
uh
college you go to north texas state
right in texas i used to go watch the uh
von eriks wrestle up there at the
sportatorium and uh being about 30 feet
from
moringa said well if those guys can do
what i can too so basically did you
wrestle in college and stuff together
like you know the regular regulation
right now i got no amateur background i
played football and everything like that
and these days it ain't about
uh you know wrestling uh technique or
anything basically yeah you
do you need to know how to wrestle yeah
but it's basically a character
personality type thing and something
that the crowd could identify with
right seeing a guy out there and uh blue
trunks going against a guy in red trunks
that's pretty uh vanilla that's pretty
generic it's pretty boring
right so you know it's a combination of
a lot of things so i saw those guys i
said you know i'll give it a shot how
many days a week you got to wrestle
well basically i'm on the road for over
200 days you know a year those are live
appearances live apparently that means
wrestling every day every night
right one of the funniest things i saw
you do is go on regis philbin and then
when you were wrestling him you punched
him in the nose like by accident
did you break his nose i was trying to
show him like the the my finishing move
the stone called stunner whatever you
want to call it right so we're basically
in the finished position i feel a guy i
mean you know
he's a great guy he's got 140 pounds
right but i felt him kind of rustling
around behind him
you know behind me you know and i was
like i think the guy's trying to take me
down or something yeah he's trying to
make himself look good i'm thinking i
got to go to work and you know
all he had 30 guys said oh yeah regis
beach on national television
right so i spun around on top of him
real quick and i shot my hand right
there in front of his face i didn't mean
to
right wink wink yeah i didn't mean to
him
i kind of clipped him in the nose but he
was a real pro man he picked up the cd
held up and
went off here he was super cool